I wasn't originally going to put down YP
Fitness I was just gonna give you what
the derivative ends up being I always
say I would ride over there in a second
that's the part that really matters what
I'm about to do but there are actually
kind of a couple things I want to point
out okay so to begin with I'm you look
at this you look at it and it's a
question there's nothing you can get
away from the question near so it's like
okay gross but let's take a deep breath
and dive in so I'm going to say you V
and then I'm gonna go ahead with the
question rule v you - those surprises
there takeaway you V - now what I get -
V - do you notice how I've written it
can you see that what I'm doing is I'm
using the in general on the denominator
okay it starts to get a little bit whoa
stuff in my head too much so if that is
the kind of position you're in there's
nothing wrong with saying that's you
that's me and then as a secondary thing
on the side say well okay you dash and B
dash will be this and this write the
number of things you have to keep in
your head at the same time it's a record
proportional to the number of silly
errors that you will make right so if
there's too much in there take some of
it out do this beforehand so that when
you get to this step you're just like
substituting you okay you don't have to
do that I didn't do that but that's
because I've done 50 million of these so
it's perfectly fine if you want to go
ahead and do that before now there's my
numerator and there's my denominator now
that you know there is gross but that's
okay I'm only trying to find stationary
points right so the numerator is really
the pot than that is for that when I get
to this point here okay can you see what
I've done try to be smart about this I
could have just expended a lot here like
it's doable it's just not very efficient
I can't you see from here if I expanded
from there I'm gonna get three times out
of that and then you get three times -
there's six terms already just the
number of places where silly errors can
creep in you're just hurting yourself
right so to be smart about it I look at
this and I say wait a second I have
simple and I ought to expect this I have
common factors happening up here right
there's an X plus two here the next
yeah there's a 2 here and this is also
something which I can factorize to add
on so that's how I pull 2 times X plus 2
out the front okay and this is what I'm
left with now from this line to this
line of a bit naughty is something I
haven't written here what have I done
I've done two things from line to line
three
well the two things okay number one I
have I've done difference of squares
there so that's good you know rather
than getting many bits of 0 - that's
good that's the first thing and the
second thing I've done is I've cancelled
out the X plus 2 down here that's why I
only end up with 3 of them not to but
you can't just do that but you can't
just cancel things out you can only do
that in certain cases why can I cancel X
supposed to know ok this is a couple
reasons
well Brendan do you wanna yes ok the
first thing is remember I am graphing
right so you come back to this guy now
even though I haven't gone through this
process yet because I'm going to be
super sketchy you know that this is
going to have an asymptote right this
guy has a discontinuity and x equals
negative 2 right so he doesn't exist
there so if he doesn't exist I don't
care about that point for the first
derivative either that's the first point
secondly because on the denominator I
still actually have it X plus 2 turn
I haven't gotten rid of the
discontinuity discontinuity is still
right there on the denominator it's the
same discontinuity with this as an X
plus 2 squared or X plus 2 so the
wonderboy X plus 2 to 100 I have
preserved that but anyhow I'm still
going to say the reason why I can cancel
it is because sorry yeah that's not
going to be 0 X comma negative then you
boil down to here I can this is my
second last step before I can actually
say what is the simplest form I could
write the derivative analyze okay
yes okay just because I'm a Finnish tip
from from this line to this line all I
did was I cancelled the X square here
and now okay I'm ready to go here is my
factorization X minus 1 and it does tidy
up quite nicely okay so what conclusion
do I draw from this like what was the
point in defining this derivative I want
to find a stationary point
okay now just let me again getting your
head the difference between excuse me a
question which says differentiate fine
station puts that's the question as
opposed to differentiate and find
stationary points that's not the
question I'm just using that as a means
to an end but the real thing I want to
do is curse sketching so here I'm gonna
be a little more fast and loose with my
insert connecting sentences and
justifying this that the other I am NOT
going to determine the nature of the
stationary point not only because I
haven't been asked to but because when I
start to put in the rest of the piece of
information that I know about this
before calculus you don't need to do
that like it's a bit overkill really I
would only do that if that was the
actual question find the stationary
point to determine their nature okay if
the real question is curve sketching
draw me a picture the nature will kind
of emerge out of that and I don't need
to do it for me I don't need to drop a
table of values I certainly don't need
to go through the second derivative
which would be rather a pain in this
case okay if the stationary point was up
lucky there makes it easier okay now
like I said interesting ly enough we all
get to that we go this question but we
do not need to like we've done these are
called rational functions right because
it's a function which has a fraction in
it and that's what gives you these on
these asymptotes an Umbreon behavior and
that kind of thing we've been looking at
those way before we learn calculus and
we knew lots of things about them the
main thing we were missing was well it
turns where is the term
exactly and you have no tools to work
out to calculate those positions but now
you do okay so in some senses then why
aren't sharing what we're doing here you
already know
don't need to release you don't need
second derivatives me it's just kind of
adds on a little bit of precision okay
as you're saying so where is my
stationary point you can just read it
off right it's when the whole thing is
zero so it's an X equal one okay start
setting it okay yeah good so I've got my
x coordinate you're going to my next
step
therefore for x equals one here's my
actual function here so I'm going to go
one takeaway for on one plus two squared
okay with that like I'm just straight
substituting in that looks to me like a
minus three on the three squared which
we've been ordering around a space
that's minus 1/3 you okay with that so
now I have coordinates now I know when I
start to get to the graph II I'll know
exactly where to put my stationary point
and there's only one that's kind of
handed them all right now that that's
out of the way is a preliminary sort
thought of um sort of thought I can do
this kind of thing with all of the
non-calculus tools I have already taught
you think about that acronym that
country which wasn't really a very good
Act yeah that's right
this is what I like to hear right and
all one of this is really easy to do now
okay
symmetry I'll just tell you in advance
because these are the kinds of questions
where it's like it's it's going to be
harder because now you know calculus
right so you have more tools to
understand what's going on you'll less
commonly find symmetry happening not
completely uncommon me right but yeah
like I said don't worry about it too
much